Oh see the clock we're so late our kids  are gonna have to tension come on come  on cells beneath your feet there is a  secret world a vast civilization where  good trolls live and evil trolls live  for centuries these lands have been  protected by one warrior  give me the ambulance troll hunter I'd  rather die the amulet will find a  champion Oh  [Music]  Master Joe have been chosen Jim you are  now responsible for the protection of  two worlds human and draw alike but if  you do not protect us hula and his army  will destroy your world I knew you had  potential you have a sweet voice but you  bring death with you  the fight is within you are you ready  the Amulet of day life challenges you to  attend to the most sacred of offices  are you master Jim or the troll hunter  so there's nowhere to go but up we  should begin your training now I had two  wives to keep up who are you Jim Blake  you've got a great look  so lucky  your worst  you're unbelievable  dance school